mr. president mr. vice president of the
Commission distinguished leaders of the
political groups honorable members of
the European Parliament I should like to
thank you for the opportunity to take
part in this debate about the future of
Europe and it is a real honor and
privilege for me to be here today as
this Democratic House represents all
European citizens human history is
driven by a desire to achieve ideals and
create better future this is exactly
what was at the birth of the European
Union 60 years ago this is what started
Democratic changes thirty years ago in
Czechoslovakia we were driven by ideals
of peace prosperity and unity the
project of the European Union brought
peace to Europe and it brought us
stability freedom and prosperity it
brought a success and even to smaller
countries like Slovakia yes
dami upon you ladies and gentlemen
Slovakia has wrote back to advanced
Europe began in 1989 driven by desire
for freedom democracy human rights
economic and technological progress by
joining the EU and NATO of 15 years ago
we made our return to where we have
always belonged I II the Western
European and transatlantic system of
values in the story of Slovakia that
followed has been one of exceptional
success nevertheless the path has not
always been easy and straightforward we
had to make it through times of economic
collapse and difficult transformation
process we've had to grapple with high
unemployment restructure the banking
sector and implement structural changes
in the economy we've built democratic
institutions under the new Slovak
sovereign statehood and we've managed to
overcome a period of democratic crisis
and we met the challenging NATO and EU
accession criteria here enlargement in
the period from 2004 until 2013 is a
classic example of a win-win process the
new member states were given the
prospects of modernization and growth
while the old member states expanded the
area of stability and single market
today Slovakia is a fully fledged member
of the European family we are among the
EU countries with the highest GDP growth
we are a stable member of the eurozone
with relatively low unemployment levels
and from a country of immigrants we have
recently become a country registering
more arrivals into it rather than people
living it the overall atmosphere in the
country has changed as well our citizens
enjoy more freedom and are richer but
they have also grown more demanding when
it comes to their political
representatives we tap into this
potential
in an effort to modernize our country
Slovakia has a robust civic society and
enjoys a high degree of media freedom we
are of course aware that there are areas
where we need to do more notably in the
education system research and innovation
potential streamlining the functioning
of state administration and curbing
corruption Slovakia story can also serve
as inspiration for the EU right now if
there is a will major challenges and
roadblocks can be overcome successful in
Milan rostislav Stephanie the great
Slovak and european diplomat one of the
founders of the Czechoslovak Republic in
1918 and our friend general said Durin's
there is nothing they cannot achieve
relu jesusí only model anemometer
valasco knee and each national journal
io out chasms Messer his message guided
us after our accession to the EU as well
at a time when a lot of work still
required completion we went through the
difficult process of joining the
Schengen and euro area we have never
come to a halt on our road to
integration as we sincerely believe in
the power and rectitude of the European
idea we consider united Europe to be the
natural environment for our existence I
am convinced that for us there is no
alternative we made this obvious also
during the Slovak presidency of the
council the Bratislava summit sent a
clear signal of unity
in the aftermath of the shock result of
the UK referendum however Slovakia just
like the rest of Europe is currently not
fully immune to the attacks against EU
values this is also true in the highly
important area of freedom of speech any
attacks on journalists trigger a
legitimate public backlash as we have
seen in Slovakia too
this is a sign of great maturity of our
democracy and our citizens it's been a
year and a couple of weeks since the
murder of the journalist Ian Kodiak and
his partner
Martina Kushner ah is this double murder
of young people sent shockwaves through
the general public as well as the
political establishment we all have one
common goal I want to show you and that
is to uncover and make the perpetrators
and as I stand here I would like to
express my gratitude to the European
Parliament including the rule of law
monitoring group for the help and
cooperation provided up until now albeit
quite critical at times and also like to
thank you Paul for their help in the
investigation which has delivered first
concrete results as several accused
persons have already been taken into
custody awaiting trial today on behalf
of Slovakia I can confirm that in these
difficult times we have every intention
of remaining in the group of the most
closely integrated EU countries we are
ready to assume our adequate share of
responsibility for the common
integration project as well as
contribute to shaping our European
future the Slovak presidential elections
are just around the corner I am
confident that the Slovak citizens will
prove their maturity by selecting a
candidate with a clear pro-european
orientation and it is my view that the
party I represent smells social
democracy being the governing party
could not have put forward and more
pro-european candidate than the
Commission vice-president mr. Marsh F
George sending a clear signal about
values to the country itself as well as
to the outside world
success story of Slovakia is to a
certain extent defined by where we come
from Central Europe is a natural living
environment for Slovakia based on our
history geography and culture after all
original political cooperation is the
essence of EU success franco-german
cooperation Weimar Benelux Baltics or
even the Visegrad group are bringing new
initiatives and ideas and thus
threatening our Union Slovakia currently
holds the presidency of the visa grad
group our main objective is to bring a
positive agenda to strengthen the EU of
course we are aware of differences maybe
even criticism and misunderstandings but
at these challenging times we need to
keep everyone on board at the table and
when we need to solve our disputes
through dialogue the European Union is
the result of a strong vision and
immense efforts of several generations
we are simply obliged to protect it
especially now when Europe and Western
democracies face dramatic new
developments we are surrounded by
challenges coming from all directions
both from inside and outside Europe we
see growing Russian and Chinese
aspirations which require a strong and
United you response we see that climate
change can have an unpredictable
economic political and societal impact
on our lives we see a new wave of
technological revolution industry 4-0
Europe as we know it will survive only
if it stays in the forefront of
technological progress and innovation to
achieve this our governments have to
become also governments for zero
moreover we face many challenges coming
from within Europe growing social
difference
destroy original social contract we face
dramatic aging of our society's regional
socio-economic disparities do not
contribute to a feeling of unity many
people feel that we are being left that
they are being left behind in this
context it is no surprise that mass
emigration from countries outside the EU
has caused new tensions and conflicts we
forgot to talk to our citizens about
Europe about democracy about our plans
for the future
when they hear no answers from us they
turn elsewheres lack of communication
can become breeding ground for this
information and fake news one example
was the British referendum in 2016 it is
obvious that isolation isolationism
protect is and protect protectionism and
nationalism are not a solution our
answer must not be fragmentation into
small national states with limited
resources but stronger unity of the EU
as a global power ladies and gentlemen
as my 17 colleagues have done already
let me be brave and determine in
presenting my vision of our common
future a vision of an attractive union
that citizens can trust and support
this still remains a valid message of
the Bratislava summit
first a union which is united prosperous
and secure second a union which is
globally relevant a union which is
honest to its citizens and Union which
cares about its own future however we
need to find a common path to achieve
our ideals so my question is how shall
we get there first we need to be united
unity was the most frequently used word
among my colleagues who have already
addressed this house and they are
completely right without unity among the
Member States we would become subject to
the decisions of others we cannot be
credible and successful in achieving our
ideas if we do not overcome the last
left overs of the former east-west
divide we have to get rid of the
stereotypes through which we perceive
our differences here I would like to
recall the world of the highly regarded
Slovak politician Milan Hodja who served
as a prime minister of Slovakia
Czechoslovakia in the 1935 thirty eight
and back in 1942 he wrote European
security cannot be built only in the
West
it also requires Central Europe and the
common democratic ideals and
institutions of both provide hope for
the future I believe that beyond
differences and geographical boundaries
they relies a common interest
we need to communicate try to understand
each other and perhaps go the extra mile
on both thighs
there are many positive examples of
differences being overcome to name just
two major examples the posting of
workers or the dual fuel food quality on
the other hand there is one major issue
on which we failed to communicate on
both thighs migration we must work out a
solution that can work for everyone
immigration must be manageable and
migration should serve the European
interests yet we cannot preserve
political unity without achieving
sufficient socio-economic convergence
and cohesion in the U in other words we
must use prosperity for the benefit of
all we must mitigate the negative
consequences of globalization and
prevent tax avoidance by corporations we
have to make them consistently pay taxes
in the countries where they really
operate and generate their profits we
have to combat growing inequalities in
society and redistribute wealth more
efficiently the introduction of an
european minimum wage would be one way
to create social solidarity my
government is particularly committed to
the european pillar of social rights
which should provide a strong social
dimension in the european union of the
future Slovakia also advocates fair
labor mobility which will allow our
citizens and companies seize the
opportunities of the single market and
therefore we welcome the agreement to
establish the European labor authority
and we have already declared our
intention of hosting it in our capital
second we need to be globally relevant
we need the EU which
plays an important global role
reflecting its economic power we must
take action to unify our forces and
increase capacity building in defense
therefore Slovakia strongly supports
permanent structured cooperation on
security and defense pesco while
ensuring complementarity between the EU
and NATO globally relevant also means
that we should uphold our long-term
commitments we are not an exclusive club
we want to be an inclusive community
open for those who fulfil criteria and
even for those who once left it is in
our strategic interest otherwise
somebody else will fill the vacuum
around us at the same time global means
having significant economic power backed
by a strong currency and based on free
but fair international trade the EU has
to remain the champion in this regard
third we need to be honest to our
citizens we cannot promise our citizens
life without problems hard work and
challenges the EU has no a magic land to
solve all problems however we can offer
our citizens a credible vision of our
future and turn that vision into
tangible deeds we need to make our
citizens and above all young people feel
a sense of ownership the EU is not some
fixes distant Brussels we are European
Union's we need to confront
we need to confront those who tell us
otherwise ignoring them or ridiculing
them is not a solution we need to
challenge them by facts the U is now a
large and strong community it provides
us with a collective identity because
there is something about the EU that is
also personal however it does not take
away our national or personal identity
our unity must be a unity of values
within the diversity of our national
regional and local cultures and finally
the fourth we need to care about the
future soon in the run-up of to the
European elections you the European
political parties will have an
opportunity to present a new realistic
vision of our union the european debate
has become very lively and intense at
many levels political and civic national
and regional my appreciations goes to
president McCrone who has significantly
stimulated these discussions with his
own vision of the future and i do agree
with him
we cannot be trapped in the state of quo
and give way to resignation we have to
renew our union it is up to us leaders
to find a common path and instruments
which citizens can trust and support
because we need freedom progress and
protection in the European Union we have
to find a way of protecting the four
freedoms that are at the core of EU
integration we need an EU why debate on
what our strategy and aspirations should
be for the middle of the century the you
will certainly have to undergo a major
transformation towards a climate neutral
economy we need a transition which is
socially just towards our citizens and
fair towards our businesses and
important issue for the future
development of the European economy is
digitalization and automation on the one
hand there is a great concern that
people will not have enough jobs because
robots will replace them on the other
hand they are great concerns about the
lack of skilled workers on the market
yet in the future we shall need even
more highly skilled people the best
evidence of this is that the countries
with the highest number of robots per
job as Germany South Korea Singapore
have the lowest unemployment rate they
are currently around 151 robots per
10,000 working places in Slovakia that
is more than half the European average
and the highest level in Central and
Eastern Europe and we should not be
afraid of technological change we only
need to adapt smart and responsible
policies if you want to be honest in our
aspiration for the future we must have
the right tools such as the next
multi-annual financial framework the
current EU budget represents only 1% of
EU GNA
focusing the budget on new challenges we
should not give up on cohesion policy
calls for its reduction in the next mff
reflect of wrong understanding of the
role of cohesion policy it is indeed
cohesion policy that helps rich and poor
regions to converge and contributes to
economic growth even in difficult
economies times I mentioned I mentioned
that we need to speak about our future
and please how can we speak about the
new mff without to have a clear vision
of the European Union
I don't think that it is a right
approach that first we see
which kind of budget we have and then we
decide what we can pay out of this
budget I think we should do it otherwise
first we have to see where we would like
to be in next 5 7 10 15 years which are
our priorities and then to decide how
big and which kind of budget for our
priorities we need this is the approach
which I like more than than what we do
in this moment and when I speak about
new technologies please we have to say
very open that and I'm not speaking
about European Parliament but in general
at the European level we are not able to
catch the speed of the development in
this area we are always behind we are
facing a digital revolution that we are
not able to do some revolution in the in
the regulatory framework we are always
behind we are trying to regulate
something which already people are using
and sometimes we are doing such a
regulation that we over regulate
everything and then we are crying why we
are not at the same level than United
States or Asia where the innovation
environment is growing up and we are
still divided in 27 or 28 28 different
regulations so please we need to think
about some flexible legal regulatory
framework not to regulate each simple
thing which is going on in our lives
because this is not the future in the
digital revolution we need to put only
some basic rules on the table and some
framework which is quite flexible enough
because we politicians are not able to
act as fast as we need to act and that's
why I mentioned the the world if we
speak about industry 4-0 we need to push
our member state that in their stage we
have also government's 4-0 because in
this moment I think we have in some
countries maybe government 2-0 somewhere
maybe 3-0 but I'm not sure if we have
somewhere government's 4-0 which are
reflecting the needs of the
ladies and gentlemen the European
elections are quickly approaching and we
need to mobilize our forces to fight
against fake news hybrid threats and
cyber propaganda make people feel the
urgency talk to them about the
importance of the U for their everyday
life make them understand that elections
matter that is their only opportunity to
steer the U and they should not let
other speaks for them there is a lot of
work ahead of us and let me finish my
speech with the words of one of the
founding fathers of European integration
Jean Monnet people only accept change
when they are faced with necessity and
only recognize necessity when a crisis
is upon them we must be brave and
determined we have to make changes and
make the union attractive to all a union
that is able able to learn from its past
mistakes in order to prepare itself to
embrace the future and once again
we need a vision of an attractive union
that citizens can trust and support
thank you for your attention
thank you very much mr. prime minister
for your speech the next speaker is the
president the European Commission
jean-claude you care bonjourno mr.
president mr. prime minister dear Peter
confianza clay well allow me to tell you
a secret I didn't sleep much because if
mrs. main last night but I slept enough
time to dream of Slovakia
because negotiating with mrs. main
yesterday I thought about the September
2016 Bratislava summit three months
after the decision of the British people
to leave the European Union your
government one of which were you apart
and you have deserved a great deal of
merit as a result of the Slovakian
presidency for the first time Slovakia
hosted a summit of the 27 EU members
because it felt that brexit belonged to
the past and it was time to prepare the
future of the European Union that's what
we did it brother Slava by adopting the
outcome document of Bratislava that
meeting took place a few days after the
State of the Union address I gave him in
the parliament and for the first perhaps
the last time the 27 prime ministers
welcomed the content of that speech it
had never happened before
and it will probably never happen again
but I will remember it as a high point
of my small political career the
Bratislava summit showed that with
courage and with determination we can
move towards a European future which
some believed would never be possible
after the British decision last night
we've reached an agreement with the
British government about the conditions
and consequences of brexit and what I
said last night that it was a second
chance but there wouldn't be a third so
I hope very much that the members of the
Parliament of the UK today support the
approach that has been adopted from it
and adopt the agreed text representing
the agreement that has been reached
Peter allow me to thank you on behalf of
the Commission for all of the support
that your government has provided and
continues to provide I'm particularly
thinking of the effort that has been
made towards innovation on the directive
for the posting of workers and the same
applies to the labor Authority I would
note also that governments that want to
host that authority on their and
territory are more numerous than those
who initially supported the creation of
such an authority
I'm delighted to hear you say the new
like the social pillar of the Univ the
European Union the more Prime Minister's
who say that not only here not just at
the Parliament but also at the council
well the less isolated I will feel
within the European Union your
government has helped us to put the
social pillar into place the special
summit which took place in good åberg
there is a need to establish social
standards in Europe that many people are
talking about the need to introduce a
europe-wide minimum wage this is not a
new idea it's something that has been
suggested since the beginning of this
commission the same applies to the
creation of a minimum revenue in all
European countries you talked about the
seven-year financial framework for the
for this budget and we need to establish
an agreed budget this is exactly what
the Commission has been working towards
that was our approach and it certainly
corresponds with the wish that you have
expressed he also said we must not
ignore the need to keep the cohesion
policy in place and I am a fervent
supporter of the cohesion policy but if
we agree on policy then as you have
yourself called for we also need not to
forget policies of innovation
modernization promoting digital economy
in defence if we were not able to review
the cohesion policy which is still a
necessity as well as the common a group
Common Agricultural Policy
we would not have been able to achieve
what we have even your government as
enthusiastic as you are would never have
accepted a budget with 141 percent total
compared to the last one so we have
proceeded according to that need
Slovakia has the presidency of the visa
grant group at the moment and I would
like you to take this opportunity today
to try to put an end to this fruitless
debate with the east of Europe and
Central Europe Europe needs to breathe
with two lungs and we need to ensure
that they are not contradicting one
another so that they can work
effectively together we all have a
contribution to make it is not just a
Commission and the European Parliament
and a few European governments of
Western Europe that are responsible for
this confrontation which is sometimes
ridiculous and certainly harmful so I
urge you to use your presidency of the
Rizk red group to remedy this situation
as you know Slovakia for us from the
west of Europe and who are relatively
young or at least who try to stay young
Slovak here for us is not a neutral
country
I was 13 years old at the time of Prague
Spring time which was also the time for
Bratislava Spring I indeed the first
movements towards that was seen in
Slovakia so we opener attention to this
country the particular affection born of
experience and hope so I hope very much
that the Slovaks do not think that the
rest of Europe does not like Slovakia
the opposite is true and I would like to
see Slovakia feel more affection towards
the European Union as well there are
historical events which are little known
the exile government of Czechoslovakia
at the time outlined a project for
Europe which they called Project for a
European Union and in this little-known
document a single phrase can be found
which is always touched me these
countries of Central Europe have wrote
the last is the last sentence we would
like to see the countries of Western
Europe join us to build the European
Union that was the government in exile
that wrote that and history prevented
them subsequently from bringing that
vision to be given that it was Western
Europe that enjoyed peace initially I
think we all have the obligation to
continue working towards the work and
the objectives we set ourselves thank
you now see Rhoda Nathan Arbuckle Marcia
thank you Joe Claude
we will now begin with speakers on
behalf political groups responds first
over to you thank you mister Janka for
your kind words thank you to the Prime
Minister a warm welcome to the